all right guys you guys know how we keep
talking about revamping the JK office
like we haven't touched in any years
there's holes from old JK party games
where we raged out there's stains on the
ground it's old it needs to be updated
and all the decor is from the old crew
which we will not mention because as you
guys know we had a big falling out we
got this whole new crew the careful boys
that we've been rocking with and we've
been crushing it for going on almost 2
years now well in the last couple of
weeks Ryan and his girlfriend smack came
through and
completely revamped our new JK news set
so I want to share it with you guys and
feast your eyes on this keep in mind
it's not completely done because they
did pretty much all of the foundation
and added even a lot of the icing but a
lot of the stuff that come in and add a
little personal touches but even right
when you walk in but bam look at that
there's this Turf there's this these
Foot Lockers this camo netting because
this is my side and even looking at
these chairs these chairs are completely
different finally some updated ass
chairs instead of some old white people
business chairs and we got some of our
merch on the
wall bessels with the boys that's so
funny that's uh one of those things that
we used to say cuz me and Nick always
try to kiss we got Jason chenny over
there rocking the Anthony Lee 911 Den
shirt show me the proof we only have one
of one of these made we've been trying
to convince Anthony like yo can you
please just let us sell it we'll give
you 100% of the profits but I understand
he doesn't want his career and dance to
be ruined so he not letting us sell but
I would love to sell that sugar is so
[__] hilarious moving on over here I
don't know how the [__] Ryan does this
[__] but he's a genius he turned this
into like our own Vegas styled cigar
whiskey Lounge type of thing like even
look look at the detail of this this
grandfather clock that's slightly tilted
it's lit it's back lit so you see the
leaves then he got this careful boys
like sign made we got this roulette
table dude actually
works and mean he he something that I
love about Ryan is he'll make things
work but also he will update things
without losing Touch of what brought the
charm in the first place you know what I
mean did that come out [__] weird so
for example like um like that for
example right there
bam so those holes are super iconic if
you are a old JK party fan and you see
us rage out and me and Joe knocked all
these holes in the wall and that is
something that all of our guests always
mention yo what happened over here and
we always have you know they a great
inspiration for conversations and
stories so instead of covering it up he
framed them to even draw more attention
but also kind of Mak it a memory and
another thing that I liked is um like
these old atak machines so at TR is old
old you know you guys most people have
people listen to streaming music before
streaming was MP3 before MP3 was CDs
before CDs was cassette tapes and when I
was a kid kid like maybe three or four
years old I barely remember eight track
and then we had these eight track
players and he put this here so it makes
that look cool and look at look at the
the design like even the painting like
that
stripe and then we had all of all our
Wards just laying on the floor back
there he put put it all up like what I
love about Ryan is I think Ryan loves us
more than we love ourselves so I feel so
grateful but yeah look at this we have
our just kidding news OG 1 million
subscriber plaque JK films JK gamer 100K
JK party 100K just getting news 100K ask
the feels I believe we have one more we
should have a JK Party 1 million one but
that one looks different cuz these are
the OG million plaques you know how they
start updating it
there is one that's uh slightly what in
the at first I thought this was taica I
was like
oh oh my God oh my okay I get the
[__] reference now do you guys get
the [__] reference you die hard JK
news fans oh my [__] God I can't
believe I didn't get
it so you guys know that one story of um
when I was a kid and my dad beat the
[__] out of me in the parking lot of
supermarket and I started running down
and then I found an Ethan Allen which is
a furniture store and I run in and I was
hiding for my life and I found a
grandfather clock this is why we have a
grandfather clock and that's why there's
a [__] Asian boy kid in there and
that's why he has his picture dude Ryan
is a [__] genius the layers of depth
to this callback reference was beyond me
I had my low IQ hat on and
wow dude Ryan you're a [__] genius
dude anyways going back look at this
sick ass paint job and then the other
thing I was like just going back to what
I was talking about with Ryan how he
likes to bring old elements into the new
like that wall remember we used to have
brick along that whole wall that texture
is stripped off as you can see it's back
to like whatever this Stucco Material is
right like he stripped it off oh wait
did he strip it off I don't know I think
he did strip it off but anyways we put
brick on there to kind of like bring
that brick from here to over there and
he made the timer professional cuz every
time people walk by they knock it down
we don't know where the remote is so
like things are not only becoming more
aesthetic it's also being more um what's
the word functional and shout outs to
James Rulo who does all of our highlight
reels that's so cool we have a little
Memorial clock for him the attention to
detail is insane all right moving on WE
moove the kjas I keep saying we like I
did it Ryan moved the kjas arcade over
here you can see it on camera this is
dope I'm sure this is some [__] deep
ass meeting is this that Clint Eastwood
movie oh it is old enough four kisses
13th in September but look at that the
old school Uncle Sam Uncle chin outfit
put in the glass case we got more
merch got these super colorful
rugs and Ryo May's favorite movie Back
to the Future in the Japanese
version and over here he even reamped
our kitchen
net like every like now it actually
feels dope because before you know when
you see on camera you would just see it
back here so it looked kind of like
ghetto where you're like wait are they
just
filming where they do things and it's
like yeah but now everything is an
intentional look so from back here now
you see this you see your drum set you
see the JK news lighting like everything
looks intentional and then he tucked
this whole thing away in here even
mounted a TV
and I'm a big details guy and the fact
that he's like hides wires and [__] and
then more paint
stripes like look at that wire
hiding it's incredible dude Ryan is
freaking amazing and it just even the
time it takes to do this door to do that
triangle and then paint all those colors
this door probably took like I don't
know 3 hours probably take me three
hours and over here he did this cool
like
Club
Vibe look at this dude that this is just
on all the time like when I come in I
don't even have to turn it on it's just
on all the time but yeah he made it all
dark and Moody the slate blue paint and
see I like that he always keeps like the
OG stuff so I drew that be a long time
ago and he's like got to keep that
that's part of it we removed all the
people we hate which is sick only the
true the true ride or die people are in
here which is really cool can't complain
when you see
boute and
boute but I probably need Ryan to walk
us through I feel like there's so many
gems in here that I'm missing out on
because he's like thinking at such a
deep level the reason why I'm here
though is uh I bought some stuff to
personalize that stff
so I'm just going to mount that and then
I can't wait till tomorrow cuz I'm going
to get everyone's reactions cuz this is
my second time seeing it the first time
I saw it it's just straight blew my mind
and Ryan may had me react to it on a
phone so I sent that to him but I was
like dude I got to share this with all
you guys so I vlogged it but I got to
set up uh I got to go to a meeting so I
got to come in real quick bang out this
setup in and uh be out
all right I started working up a storm
and then I forgot that La is humid so I
started sweating and I didn't want to go
to my meeting like all sweaty and stuff
so I took off my shirt so don't mind me
but I was going to put up the
flag and it ended up covering the whole
thing so I'm like dude I'm going to need
Ryan's design eye to come and show me
what he thinks will look best but I was
able to dig in the JK props and pull out
my old military stuff so I redesigned
what he did and I think came out really
good so I put the Molly pack right there
it's not even Molly is it I forgot the
name of it we put the pack right here
put the old combat boots Put the Kevlar
without the cover I felt like it
balanced out with the green got the
canteen Kar put the little hat AKA cover
and then the little Blood Sport shout
outs to Ryan for knowing all my favorite
stuff putting here now this background
looks really really
cool that's what all the background's
like look
like yep that's about it for today um
I'll uh probably have to find through
some stuff tomorrow but I can't wait to
get everyone's reactions tomorrow all
right Ryan this is the Maestro behind
all this crazy stuff yeah what inspired
you to like like how were you inspired
what's what I what am I trying to say
what am I trying to say um like how did
you know what to do and what was like
your creative Direction I I just thought
about us man I just thought about us as
dudes and I thought it'd be really funny
to have like each side be representative
of like each person a little bit and um
like with this side it it reminds me a
lot of Anthony and kind of the jokes
that we make as like being pseudo
gentlemen yeah like so we wanted to um I
guess like make something that looked
kind of like a like a vintage man cave
sort of thing oh you know like like a
smoking Lounge like a smoking room like
from back in the day like a whiskey
Cigar Lounge exactly yeah I forgot what
you call those things yeah but then it
kind of looks like that sex hav pad yeah
exactly and then uh and then I wanted to
just put everything mainly like items
wise was the most important thing was
for people like JK audience to see their
comments like in front of them cuz you
know they we have so many inside jokes
with them over the years and so many
recurring themes everywhere in the DMS
and I'm like be so great for them to see
that that's the most important thing was
having your guys started all yeah start
all you know like it's crazy that we
don't have anything uh I guess like
pertaining to that in in JK I'm like
dude we need that and uh yeah it's crazy
I feel like there's so many [__]
layers and you can if you want a a part
of JK history you get this at merchlabs
docomo merchlabs
docomo what's the code again
there's no code what's the website
again merchlabs
docomo we should get a code where if
they put it in it's like 20% more
expensive
yeah yeah like I feel like there's so
much um like layers yesterday uh did you
have fun looking through like the James
rulfo one like I already I already
caught it on the Vlog but no [__]
[__] I was walking around and I was
just vlogging like just talking what
ever and I literally would came to this
section right and then I was like that's
pretty cool grandfa clock and I was
like grandfather clock and it [__]
blew my mind I was like oh [__] yeah you
like that Asian Asian yeah and there's a
baby in there and then this one yeah
this one and this one got an AI version
of that was crazy yeah man I mean that
was the detail the detail it's aesthetic
wise it's pretty simple but I mean the
the complicated part was just fitting in
all of the different details that we
have over time you know cuz there's so
much stuff that we've said and done and
like things that are so iconic stuff
that was already iconic here like even
that dut that's been behind your head
for the past forever now it's on to you
know smov it cuz I'm like I don't want
to lose certain things and your painting
that we took down thank you thank you
like I want to find a place for
everything you know this I'm so glad
Back to the Future and the wait is that
custom made yeah that one is custom made
that one was like made by a prop a prop
house back in the day that was when I
had my Del and I had that commissioned
ages ago so it's super solid and then
next to it the Japanese Back to Future
poster this guy
ja think the most important thing is I
wanted the fans to feel like like this
era belongs to them too cuz you know
like cuz they're sitting here staring at
an era from way back you know like not
bun people that we [__] hate and
[__] I was walking through the hallway I
was like good all the people we hate
aren't on here anymore I heard that yeah
isn't it crazy
like we even though we [__] hate
their
guts that on the in the hallway we would
walk by every single day and I would see
their childhood pictures and I was like
oh that's the person that I [__] hate
their guts
of and we know took it
down but yeah it's like it's been such
an iconic era like it just needed a like
a fresh feeling in terms of
environment and it just needed a good
cleaning yeah you know what my favorite
part about all of this is yeah what is
it we created this whole feeling that JK
was on its way out of YouTube yeah but
you know what the real deal is we are
the Cockroaches of YouTube we can
survive a nuclear attack which we did
and people thought oh they're done well
guess what rebirth baby rebirth and on
top of that 2 million subscribers and on
top of that 2024 we're just going to
keep making new content and keep going
we're going to be like the first
60-year-old
YouTubers that would be [__] sick no
there's actually senior YouTubers I know
no but they're not of Our Generation
they're not like us cuz we're like gen
one or gen 1.5 us and Wong Fu long
surviving cuz if you're like 60 you need
jump on that's kind of cheating cuz you
weren't there from the [__] the piano
we're from the cats on the piano era
yeah we're from Charlie bit my finger
era dude yeah you remember that [__]
yeah he's a gen one YouTuber
yeah open yeah now we're going to get
reaction are you by yourself huh are you
by yourself yeah by myself all right all
right
cool up check out our new set dude it's
pretty cool man welcome what the [__]
shut the [__] up you're outside
still this SMS like waa dude is crazy
bro what the [__] I like how he said
what the [__] to just that corner
this corner is crazy we should have
closed the door after
that you you didn't even see any of it
yet how many days did this take you to
do this is absolutely insane right like
six days what the [__] you [__]
killed it huh take a walk I was like
Jesus [__] Christ come this way come
this way this is your new home it's your
new home man we got chairs we got new
chairs what the [__] bro we have a whole
what is this what do you call this this
backarat we got
bakarat rouette yeah that's what I
said holy [__] dude isn't this [__]
crazy okay this guy was asking me he's
like give me some stuff like could put
like on the uh on the walls and I was
like I don't think I have anything to
put got a black B I was like put a
picture of my dogs man [__] your dogs
man what the [__] dude this is
incredible dude this was meant to be
your This was meant to be your Jiu-Jitsu
podium
yeah really second place it's to be a
second place Podium oh my God so
cool we're going to make a is this
really going to be a Jiu-Jitsu podum it
was it was but now we're just going to
put merch So then whenever whenever
guests come we'll just have Merch this
look so [__] crazy this is beyond
what I had pictured in my
head dude we have a cutting board we
finally have a cutting board
oh my gosh cutting board is it crazy
look at [__] is this place place
[__] insane we got a club in here we
got a we got a straight club in here
dude we have nectar hard
Seltzer yeah you're like yeah no but
even looking at this door I was like
dude did that door take like 2 hours or
something 2 hours yeah I can't imagine
how long this all took yeah you know it
took longer just sorting the bathroom
shelf
yeah the the the yeah even the Practical
stuff even the Practical stuff is dope
look at that dude did you see Joe did
you see that picture above the toilet
yeah I I saw
this yeah it's from the from the episode
I can't believe you found
it who goes there
yo who's
yo you
know are you going to open the door oh
yeah
I was like how do I open the door with
my hands on the
camera
hello welcome to the new office welcome
sir come on in welcome to the new office
we're not pranking you or doing anything
nothing's going to fall on your head
we're just getting this is an anti
hoodie worth $1,000 no no we're just
we're just getting actual reactions of
of the set holy
[__] right holy [__] it actually looks
cool in
here oh my God welcome to your new home
oh my God this is [__] crazy that
Chain's icy though I'll tell you that
you like this
[__] chain had to get it when it became
such a huge percent of my
portfolio cuz I'm crushing the game dude
this you got to see the rest see the
rest oh yeah look at the rest you got to
see you got to see your Colts room in
the back get the [__] out of here yeah
Ser kitchenette it's now a [__] CTS
room look at the color on the wall oh my
God you guys are the best dude this is
awesome Anthony did this all by
himself I don't believe that I don't
believe that dude bro you're amazing
isn't he amazing this is [__]
incredible doesn't make sense this is
like a cool spot
yeah like we can take chicks here dude
we can actually take women
here wow this is so slick we're finally
going to get laid dude we going to get
hey
yay we could have parties here we could
invite girls going be awesome we're on
the up and up boys all right so we just
filmed a full day worth of JK news at
our brand new set ran a little bit late
today it's 8:40 but everything turned
out sick looks amazing it was dope for
all the boys get back together except we
don't have Anthony of course is
traveling but to see all the new videos
that we just shot make sure you go to
just kidding news on YouTube go check
out all that new content in our new set
comment let us know what you like any
other inside jokes that we should put on
the wall and uh we'll see you guys next
time peace all right so Anthony is the
only one who hasn't seen the office yet
cuz he's been in La um dancing for their
new golf carts and he's just here hey
Ryan can you open the the want we got to
get his reaction he's all yelling at us
dude that's some Southeast Asian anger
right there dude
rage come here open it I got no hand oh
okay check out the new office dude
that's why you have no hands yeah I got
no hands what's up man hey check out the
new office oh [__] this is obviously my
corner represents me the most holy [__]
oh wait why am I locking it oh my and
the chairs just [__] crazy huh oh oh
man how the that's brand new that's no
history
here Jenny
Manas dude it look oh my gosh isn't this
place [__] incredible it's almost
like we're proud of this place we are
proud bro what are you talking about
we're not proud boys we're careful boys
dude dude look we still can't use this
space but it's still cool yeah we can
yeah storage oh my good oh look these
are actually up see pride see I told you
oh my goodness look at this grandfather
clock over here do you know the
significance oh Ethan Allen
yeah my goodness Ryan did this for you
that's for you man oh my gosh it's kab B
so you have free promo this is I think
like 40 bucks a month that you have to
pay at space for dude yeah so you bucks
a month you have to you guys got to pay
at space for this no we need first and
last month that's only $80 first and
last month you already need $80
dude space this is crazy oh my
God D this this is Steve's Corner
oh my wow
wow W believe all women oh this still
looks like [__] yeah that looks like
[__] no but they organize it still it's
just can [__] it up they organize it
can [__] it up oh oh you brought that
yeah oh why is this still up dude what
are you talking about that's genius
that's Masterpiece
yo this is crazy this is the skinniest
Bart's legs have ever been let see
look at that that's that's the pre
Vietnamese coffee
legs this is [__] mind BL oh my
goodness why is this still here this is
just n it's part of the decoration
that's annoying though all right
fine dude you see the cult stripes for
Steve yeah oh my rinae sentimental dude
yeah we're not even I'm gay I thought
that was R stes for Ryan like I thought
that was Cowboys n I'm gay bro yo oh
snap you get you kept all the shitty
signs see you kept the old and the new
and made the new the old and the old the
new but suddenly it's like it makes way
more sense and it looks way better
suddenly already steeg red bulles from
yesterday oh my God four of them of
course it is yeah you got to check out
this road